[Applause]
well this is very thoughtful
and ridiculous because I'm only going to
Boston and you know I'll probably be
here next week God says great will you
just let us host you
Meredith gray
Meredith gray says goodbye to gray Sloan
it's still Grace she's still there in
spirit and that's the house that gray
built so she's always there looming she
just has to step away for a little bit
the Gray's Anatomy winter Premiere
marked Ellen pompeo's final episode as a
series regular and for mayor she had
some things to take care of during her
final shift in Seattle big last day yeah
we're trying to forget all that and act
like everything is super normal how are
we doing not great when it came to Dr
Gray's final surgery at her OG Hospital
things didn't go as planned come on
Tessa fight
mayor Meredith like Griffith take over
time of death 12 21.
this was my last surgery here
that for sure I was going out on a high
but mayor sure felt the love when it was
time for the doctors to say goodbye you
know Once Upon a Time
bane of my existence but no you grew up
to become
one of my greatest points of Pride
I'm we keep
[Music]
okay go go Dr Gray where Dr babe is
trying to say is
this place won't be the same without it
it's a really exciting time and even
Meredith says look I'll be back next
week or next month but for the the
character it's such an interesting
Journey when you have to say wait a
minute I have to take care of my family
and I have to do what my family needs
and if that takes me someplace else and
then I can figure out another way to
fulfill my profession that's great Ellen
first scrubbed in as Meredith in 2005.
did you choose me for the surgery
because I slept with you
yes
okay
I'm kidding I know we have a hit every
Monday morning when the ratings stay
what they are but you know I try not to
be presumptuous or assume anything and I
take it week by week 19 seasons and more
than 400 episodes later fans aren't
ready to let her go one tweeted I cannot
believe we're saying goodbye to one and
only Meredith gray while another says
Meredith gray is Iconic and I'm crying
it's inspired so many generations of
healthcare workers so I think for for
the young people it's a really good
piece of content and we're going to try
to keep it going for the young people
not necessarily with me but you know to
keep it going Beyond me but don't worry
because we will see Dr Gray again
Ellen's expected to appear one more time
before the season's over for the record
it's not really my final it's a little
bit of a trick they're playing on people
um it is my final episode for a while
and she'll continue as narrator I never
thought I'd be asked to speak any more
than I already do but um
[Music]
thank you